mindless eating how many of you have sat
on the couch and eating a whole bag of
chips without realizing it I realized it
but you do have you done it come on put
your hands up really be honest here you
know and then you go I can't believe I
get the whole thing well here to show us
how to be more aware of our hunger cues
please welcome dietician Abby sharp
you're not you're not really worried
about what we're eating as much as how
much we're eating how we reach how are
you yes like you said we tend to eat
mindlessly we do a shot the whole bag of
chips um one go yes but you know there
easily we can do about it and requires
no dieting right which is what we love
so portion control and that's right
absolutely so so we're gonna tell it to
talk a little bit today okay I want to
talk about this before we get started
you inherited your grandmother's dishes
I did and what did you notice about that
they were so much smaller than what I'm
used to using at home
yeah because the plates are like charger
yeah so we're gonna talk about that in
just a minute
what do you have right here at me well
we're gonna get started over here so the
key to mindful eating is really
listening to your body
yeah it's chunky and when it's time to
write write write and you know to do
that
I like to think about my body kinda like
a car okay so what a car
okay go I'm the Ferrari let's say I'll
write your Ferrari the Ferrari oh and
I'm a car my body's my hungers like my
gas tank
mm-hm and my mom always said you don't
want to wait till you're running on
fumes before you fill up your gas tank
right cuz you got to go to that really
seedy gas station or a really expensive
one and you limit your choices yes you
do but we do this all the time with our
hunger right we wait till we're super
starving yeah and then we binge on
everything we see to the point we're so
full we need to unbuckle our belts not
good mm-hmm so instead I want you to
start eating Royalle else three or four
okay can we go through these levels sure
I mean we don't really really need to
physically when you're too hungry you're
not yet
irritable on it hurry hangry hangry
fling event and then shaky and loss of
phone right right too much so instead I
want you to start eating around levels
three or four so just when you feel like
you know I could go for a little
something something that's what you're
going okay good to know
and then I want you to stop eating right
around level seven or eight so just when
you feel okay I'm satisfied but I'm not
stopped okay I got you
you read these things okay so when
you're shaky and losing focus that's
that's not we don't want that you want
stomach growling and a little hungry
just a little bit thinking of yeah
so when you say between level like that
a quarter three-course we pull you
really give yourself some wiggle room so
that way you can make healthier more
mindful choices rather than those crazy
friends so let me ask you this in this
neutral zone yes which I'd like to be in
that's what we won over - sounds fine
you can sense food is in your stomach
yes and you've got it you've got to feel
that yeah I think we eat so quickly yes
that we don't sense that at all exactly
so in order to find that middle ground
yes you really got to pay attention okay
and to do that you don't want to be
distracted so my next tip is to adjust
your environment so that you can get
eating your undivided attention
okay good okay so when it's time to eat
I want you to sit down get rid of the
distractions power down turn the TV off
Internet away and portion your food into
a bowl or on a plate so that means no
eating out of the box or in the bag or
off your kids plates right over the sink
or the sink so because it's food go
straight from like the bag to your mouth
or when you're distracted by technology
and work your mind doesn't really
acknowledge you're eating anything at
all so you just sit anywhere with these
chips yeah hey there's chips this should
watch the game that's right and this is
all I'm gonna have that's it and once
that's gone that's gone see you later
that's it let's talk about what you got
here they're very healthy snacks here
but not a lot of cheese great just works
in our small just portion control that's
all you got to worry about cereal cereal
and a little bit of almonds is Siri this
is this what that would be like you know
if you were having that of us as a snack
or as a portion that's all you got to
stick to just make sure it goes in a box
sorry in a bowl or a plate and you're
going to go okay what do you have here
okay so even when we do sit like
actually sit down right a lot of us
shovel the food in so quickly we can't
really acknowledge those satiety signals
right so in a really great tip is to use
chopsticks which I can't use instead of
a fork so I will be shaken okay that's
okay that's okay good but just like so
you want you I want you to grab the
chopsticks I'm going on the fork here
now it's okay if you're not good hmm do
you see how much weren't rice
we can get on the fork then on the
chopsticks right yeah that's really
gonna sell you hey yeah but we really
gonna slow you right okay gotcha
that's right okay now let's move on to
portions cuz this is where a lot of
people get shredded up plates cut the
plates right okay so have you heard the
Adagio eat with your eyes Yeah right
well they're one of the biggest mindless
eating traps that I see people fall into
is it turning
how much to eat based on how much you
see fitting on your plate rather than
listen to your actual body's needs right
right and that's the goal we want to
listen to our body but it takes a little
bit of practice so while we're honing
our mindfulness skills we can use some
of those nasty little traps to our
advantage and all you got to do is swap
out your large size plates for smaller
size sets like my grandma sets okay
because perfect exactly look at these
two servings of pasta if you serve this
pasta you call it probably quite
satisfied right sure but the same amount
of pasta a little on sticky yeah so
you're gonna load it up and yeah yeah
you know taking twice as many calories
you not even notice right that's the
theft amazing thing that's good I'll
tell you my parents used to eat off
their little plates like that all they
did and that was enough exactly and they
didn't have so many health problems back
then no no that's right they didn't
that's okay okay now eat what you love
unlike this the most important tip okay
if you don't remember nothing else is to
eat what you love and never let yourself
feel guilty about it I know it's kind of
radical sounding well on a dietitian I'm
telling you to eat what you love yeah
and I got cake right here and it's good
cake it's good cake but you know think
about it when you eat foods just cuz
they're healthy your locale or your diet
book says you should the minute you get
your hands on what you really want
you're gonna probably devour the whole
thing in one go right yeah meanwhile
you're even much better off just to have
mindful moderate portions of all the
foods that you love so what if you have
that here's my cure yeah I have that
yeah that's still in the refrigerator
but I have that and I go that was really
good just so eat it slowly in this way
use all these tips yes slowly sit down
savor it yeah and you literally at the
moment you give yourself permission to
enjoy that cake yeah that dessert eat
the entire thing is gonna go away how
many of
say okay and I'm guilty of this too I'm
not gonna eat that like I would I really
want that pasta that was look if I go no
no no you're not having that pasta what
you're saying is don't you didn't have
it so if you go for dinner
yeah for example a friend of mine does
is she or is she says can I have the
appetizer portion back and I'd like to
share it with my friends
exactly so that's what you're saying how
thing enjoy it right really savor it and
when you give yourself you know you
don't make foods taboo or all right so
bad that desire to kind of you know
binge on something right you shouldn't
really be a one go away having I wonder
when that happen though I wish we got to
really turn that arousal it's your
probably everybody